euh on va revenir sur cette confusion
hier à l'Assemblée nationale après le
décès d'Alexandra agricultrice de 36 ans
plusieurs élus ont voulu observer une
minute de silence pour lui rendre
hommage c'est le cas d'André chassigne
du groupe communiste qui a formulé la
proposition mais tout le monde n'a pas
été de C avis notamment à gauche et chez
Renaissance on vous explique tout dans
un instant après ce mini recap
dites-nous ce que vous en pensez
êtes-vous choqué par cette minute de
silence refuser que certains députés LFI
écolo et Renaissance refusent de faire
une minute de silence à l'Assemblée
national en hommage à l'agricultrice
tuée êtes-vous choqué dites-nous
[Musique]
oui ces derniers jours les agriculteurs
font entendre leur colère avec des
manifestations partout en France mais
hier dans l'Ariège une agricultrice et
sa fille ont été tué par une voiture qui
a forcé un barrage et ce drame risonne
en chacune et en chacun d'entre nous
alors pour leur rendre hommage le groupe
communiste a proposé de réaliser une
minute de silence dans l'hémicycle mais
certains députés à l'instar de
l'insoumis Eric cochrel s'y sont opposés
l'homme a notamment demandé une minute
de silence supplémentaire pour deux
jeunes tués à Saint-Denis CD avait 14
ans faride 18 faute d'accord la minute
de silence n'a donc pas été observé
alors les députés LFI etcolo et
Renaissance refusent de faire une minute
de silence à l'Assemblée en hommage à
l'agricultrice tuée êtes-vous
choqué alors les chéris jeis vous donner
les raisons par exemple il y en a un
avec qui je peux comprendre le seul que
je peux comprendre je vous dis c'est
Sylvain Maillard parce que je vais vous
dire pourquoi il a dit non c'est le
président du groupe Renaissance Sylvain
Maillard je peux comprendre enfin à la
limite voilà c'est le seul parce que le
reste je vais vous dire ce qu'il a dit
SV ma il a observé d'OB il a refusé
d'observer une minute de silence parce
que lui ce n'était pas pour une raison
politique mais plutôt en lien avec le
règlement de l'Assemblée nationale qui
dispose de règles particulières pour les
minutes de silence ça à la limit Sylvain
Maillard je vous dis la vérité lui je le
comprends voilà Sylvain Maillard après
Éric coqurel député LFI vous allez dire
que je tape toujours sur les mêmes mais
forcément c'est toujours les mêmes qui
font les conneries donc forcément lui
voilà il a voulu mettre une condition
qu'une autre minute de silence soit
respecté pour les deux adolescents tués
la semaine dernière à saint-is sur base
de rivalité entre quartiers en fait
c'est une battle de c'est toujours
excuse amis c'est pas mes
amis rglut dans la poli exaement syv il
est dans le règlement je comprends voilà
Sylvin may voilà on pe on peut rien lui
dire voilà on peut rien lui dire cyiel
châelin tiens la présidente du groupe
les écologistes à l'Assemblée étai sur
la même ligne qu'É Corel qui ressemble
ça semble il y a Sandrine Rousseau
euh Sandrine Rousseau bien entendu
député écolo de Paris qui a posté un
tweet qui a fait énormément réagir avant
de le supprimer je l'ai dit hier ceux
qui font ce que font les agriculteurs
depuis 2 jours explosion dans un
bâtiment une personne tuée rail dégradé
est inadmissible et le silence du
gouvernement est absolument incroyable
encore de la politique de Sandrine
Rousseau voilà Sandrine Rousseau elle se
fait énormément remarquer bien entendu
et c'est vrai que on se fait beaucoup
plus remarqué quand on écrit des des des
inipsies autre réaction qui a beaucoup
fait réagir c'est celle de Yannick Jad
sénateur écolo qui s'est énervé et là
moi je trouve sa réaction inadmissible
la réaction de Yannick jado une fois de
plus Yannick jado voilà franchement il
il est gentil mais Yannick jananck jado
sans rigoler il a une tulipe dans le
cerveau excusez-moi il dit que les
écolos seraient dé gens en prison s'il
faisait autant que les agriculteurs
écoutez ce qu'il dit il est gentil en
plus c'est pas possibleez que le
gouvernement doit ordonner l'évacuation
de ces barrages routier est-ce qu'il y a
un deux poids de mesure par rapport à la
gestion de certains blocag des mitemps
écologistes bah il est évident si vous V
et vous avez dernière rénovation qui
bloque une autoroute sur la question du
climat pendant un quart d'heure ils sont
en garde à vue et les procès tombent et
les sanctions tombent les écologistes
feraient le millième de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui il seraient en prison et
condamné quand on défend l'intérêt
général on est immédiatement sanctionné
quand on défend des intérêts
corporatistes qui sont légitimes
aujourd'hui on n pas les mêmes réponses
que la FNSA mais non mais alorsand je
dis il a une Tuul dans le cerveau parce
que je VO oui image non mais c'est pas
ça c'est que voilà il pensent que voilà
mais les gars quel rapport entre les
agriculteurs les agriculteurs compr y
jado on parle pour leur survie on parle
de leur travail tous les jours yanck
jado bien sûr bien sûr qu'il faut
préserver la planète mais on parle de de
de quelque chose qui n'est pas n'est pas
immédiat et puis ça n'a rien à voirar
incomparable mais comment on peut être
mais c'est pas possible de dire ça oui
encore une fois les la France fait
preuve d'une grande démagogie il tentent
de faire de la récupération politique
business électoral c'est précisément la
SC Sadni et les quartiers populaires la
SC Sadni c'est 11 circonscriptions sur
ces 11 circos ils ont sur ces 12 CIRC
pardon ils ont 11 députés il il compare
l'incomparable c'est une Rix évidemment
toute mort et dramatique personne ne le
remet en cause or là c'est totalement
différent et les les communistes les
communistes eux se grandissent les
communistes n'ont plus rien à voir avec
laanupes dans laanupes on a un bloc
Islam gauchiste aujourd'hui porté par la
France insoumise qui fait de la
récupération à T va et on a un bloc on a
un bloc qui est plus républicain que le
que le reste de cette alliance tout le
monde va pas réagir parce que tout le
monde est d'accord on a un autre débat
derrière
avec le maire de Marignan mais juste oui
pour revenir à la minute de silence je
ne comprends pas comment un homme
politique normalement constitué peut
avoir l'idée de créer un débat autour de
la mort tragique d'une agricultrice
d'une famille décimée en plus parce que
je crois que sa fille a succombé ses
blessures est Mor hierir dans la soirée
à quel moment on crée un débat làdessus
il y a pas débat voyez pas qu'ils osent
tout et je l'ai dit je le mets à part et
quand vous dites il osent tout c'est
justement pour faire parler deux pour se
démarquer pour faire du buz le buz c'est
bien quand c'est au détriment du respect
et voilà sur la mort de quelqu'un c'est
lament qui critique un peu ses amis ça
ça me fer plaisir c'est honteux j'ai
honte j'ai honte que vous puissiez que
vous puissiez massimiler à ces gensl
aujourd'hui j'en ai honte
par il
est 5 je VO mais c'est honteux c'est
scandaleux ce qu'ils ont fait c'est du
mépris de classe pour le monde rural
pour les agriculteurs pour cette famille
deuillé pour cette lutte effectivement
des des agriculteurs pour leurs
exploitations pour leur survie c'est
dégueulasse voilà le le le mot me sort
comme ça c'est pas un bon mot mais c'est
dégueulasse franchement comment on peut
faire ça quand on est un élu c'est
irresponsable de leur part ça me fait
vomir excusez-moi je pouvez arrêter de
me faire ça depuis tout à l'heure
anecdote je le prends mal et en plus
c'est une fausse
info je le sais malheureusement voilà
donc arrêtez de me faire ça est-ce qu'il
arrête pas de m'interpeller et me faire
ça ça suffit maintenant parce que je
sais qu'il faut faire cours quand vous
voulez parler vous faites
ça ok merci qu'est-ce que vous voulez
non je voulais dire il y a de il y a
deux agriculteurs qui suicident par jour
lu fait leur situation il y a pas deux
écologistes qui suicident par jour au vu
de la planète donc quand même de poids
c'est pas situation pas même c'est d'une
excuse-moi mais comment on peut mais
c'est pas possible de toute façon je
vais vous dire on pour débattre pendant
des heures des inepties qui sont qui
sont raconté par ces gens et Monsieur
Maillard de renaissance ok d'accord il y
a un point de règlement je suis d'accord
mais malgré tout il faut pas oublier que
cette pauvre agricultrice et sa fille
ils ont été sapés par par tris TF et
malgré tout les TF s'ils sont en France
c'est à cause de notre gouvernement qui
n'arrive pas ou qui n'y arrive pas à les
renvoyer il a pasah oui mais donc la
France est responsable de
Mor c'est pas le débat c'est un autre
débat on fer peutêtre c'est pas le débat
justement on va passer au B du jouroui
qu'est-ce qu'il veut B non parce pour
rester sur le débat en fait quand tu
vous mélangez entre une Rix le député
qui dit oui il y a eu des r en on a pas
fait de minut de silence SAU que la
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas l'état en
fait là les agriculteurs pourquoi
pourquoi il y a ce drame là parce que
l'État a pas fait ce qu'il fallait pour
sauver les agriculteurs donc ils sont
dans la rue maintenant donc
indirectement l'État est aussi un peu
responsable de pour
les Galine oui ça oui mais c'est non
c'est pas tout à fait le même débat veut
dire absolument que c'est le même débat
voilà si c'est pour ça c'est pas parce
que vous m'avez prêté un
[Applaudissements]
collier m' pas avec un collier
incorruptible voilà merci gine merci